في في تلك الفتره لم يعني لم تكن هنالك
اتصالات في الفتره الاخيره ليش لان بعد ما
نشرت ااا
[موسيقى]
كانت هنالك رده فعل في تونس وحتى في بعض
البلدان الاخرى التي كانت معانيه بمنشورات
ويكيليكس وهي
تجميد الاتصال مثل العلاقات تجميد
الاتصالات هذا ولكن البروسيس او المسام
سابق لان هي كانت عندما تقابلت معها
هي كانت في جوله يعني احاطه بما يجري هذا
ما قالته في في مذكراتها الخيارات الصعبه
وقالته بوضوح يعني يوميه وكانت على اتصال
حتى ببعض اطراف تونسيه كانت موجوده التقطت
مع بعض البعض منهم يعني لو كان هنالك
الولايات المتحده كانت تريد ان تغير هذا
يعني التوازنات الجهويه
الاتصالات كانت قائمه والعلاقات مع امريكا
هناك صداقه التونسيه امريكيه قديمه يعني
حاولوا همم حاولنا عده مرات مش حواله يعني
كانت مواقف تون السعاده
امام التحديات الجديده للشبكات الارهاب
الى الاخريه
في الاراضي همم التونسيه وحتى في اراضي
يعني المغرب العربي كله الاتحاد المغاربي
وهذا مطروح من ايام كوندايزر عايش ومن
ايام يعني قبل قبل الامريكي تحديدا والرفض
التونسي شو هو بالضبط
[موسيقى]
كنت انا في التجمع
وامين قال التجمع الدسوري الديمقراطي
الحزب الحاكم على الحزب الحاكم
وكان معي في وفد مشينا الولايات المتحده
وكنت اتصلنا ببعض
الناس في نيويورك توصلنا به وتسمى بالخصوص
اندرس
النائب وكاتب الدوله وزير الخارجيه
الامريكي اللي عنده شؤون الشرق الاوسط
شمال افريقيا
بتاع الارهاب تحدي الاسلامي
الاسلام يعني مش تحدي الاسلامي تحدي
الاسلام السياسي
رؤيه تونس هو ان تونس تحتاج الى شيء من
الوقت
لتدرسته في بدايه التسعينات او اواخر
الثمانينات من اصلاحات
ولكن
وقتها احسست
بوضوح انا واقف موقف الامريكان هو دائما
ادمجهم في اللعبه السياسيه
وهكذا تبنى الديمقراطيه وكان مثلا همم
فقدت عدد الى اخره
تلك الايام كان سبقتها ما جرى في الجزائر
بعد الانتخابات
[موسيقى]
ال ال
الديمقراطيه لا يمكن ان تكون الا في دوله
مدنيه يعني يفصل فيها بين الدين والسياسه
الدين يبقى للشخص لعقيدته والدين هو ميدان
تاب على المقدس ماهوش تابع اليوم
ولكن الميدانيه لم تفصل الامور لان كل ما
تحرك
تحرك الشارع يعني بيعازم من الاسلاميه او
كل ما وقعت عمليه ارهابيه تجد ان الامور
تتغير
والرياكشن يعني
تحدث بعد الاشكاليه الى اخره